a recent gamespot instagram post has
caught the attention of fans over on the
harry potter game subreddit i'll break
down
all the details for you here in today's
video so guys after digging into this it
seems that warner brothers has indeed
confirmed a morality system for hogwarts
legacy
via a slightly updated official q a this
is the q a
on the hogwarts legacy website and it
was picked up by the gamespot instagram
account
we'll break down that post and also take
a look at the full faq to see what other
details we can confirm and we're
starting right now
people of the internet retro rack and
tour here if we're meeting for the first
time i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
also if you're new here we have a ton of
hogwarts legacy content on the channel
i'll be sure and link you to a playlist
at the end of the video here
where you can see our full coverage for
the game the devs at avalanche software
officially unveiled hogwarts legacy at
the ps5 showcase event back in september
and things have been mostly pretty quiet
as far as updates go
at least until now for me it started
when i came across this reddit post with
the title
gamespot on instagram confirms hogwarts
legacy will have a morality system
sure enough there's a link to the
official gamespot instagram which does
indeed confirm this the instagram post
reads as follows
warner brothers explained at their
recent q a session regarding hogwarts
legacy that the game would feature a
morality system stating that quote
players will also encounter missions and
scenarios that will challenge their
morality and determine what they stand
for
close quote my first thought after
reading this was okay what
recent q a session are they talking
about here as far as i'm aware there
haven't been any recent events or
official statements from warner brothers
or
avalanche it would appear that gamespot
is actually referencing the official
faq on the hogwarts legacy website i
went there to confirm this
and found the quote used in their
instagram post but
there's more the full quote has more
information that you may or may not have
known already depending on when you last
checked the website
it reads how do you play hogwarts legacy
and then they go on with the answer here
hogwarts legacy is filled with immersive
magic putting players at the center of
their adventure to become the witch or
wizard they choose to be
they will grow their characters
abilities as they master powerful spells
home combat skills and select
companions to help them face off against
deadly enemies
players will also encounter missions and
scenarios that will pose
difficult choices and determine what
they stand for
so this is exciting for a few reasons
first off it does indeed confirm a
morality system which we already felt
pretty strongly about but it's good to
have it confirmed here
the wording is particularly interesting
though because they call out both
missions and scenarios as it relates to
player choice
so to me this makes it even more
probable that our choices are going to
have
real in-game consequences maybe even
diverging story paths
but it's not just the morality bit
that's interesting here
they also confirm we'll be able to
select companions to help face off
against deadly enemies
this is really exciting because
hopefully it means we're going to be
getting a strong cast of side characters
to accompany us on our journey
we all know harry wouldn't have made it
nearly as far in his journey without
loyal companions like ron hermione luna
and neville
there are also three entries directly
related to the game's story and i know a
lot of you have been wondering how it
fits in
so let's take a look at those first the
question how does hogwarts legacy fit
into the wizarding world
while port key games are not direct
adaptations of the books and films
the games are firmly rooted in the harry
potter universe
while remaining true to jk rowling's
original work port key game developers
chart new territory by creating fresh
ways for fans to immerse themselves in
the wizarding
world a few bits here that stand out
namely they say the games are quote
firmly rooted in the harry potter
universe close quote
i think this should give a lot of
longtime fans comfort that they're going
to be respectful of the world that's
been built and we aren't likely to see
any huge
cannon altering developments it should
also be encouraging that they're being
given the freedom to explore new ideas
to further improve our immersion in the
wizarding world
okay the next two questions are a little
redundant but they list them separately
so i'll do the same here
the first reads is hogwarts legacy an
original story
and then the follow-up question to that
is what is the original story of
hogwarts legacy
here they again confirm the details
about the game being set in the late
1800s
it's also clear they're placing a heavy
focus on student life at hogwarts
stating we'll be able to grow our
magical abilities by mastering spells
brewing potions and taming fantastic
beasts
it seems the core plot of the story will
be centered around a
dangerous journey to uncover a hidden
truth
of the wizarding world like you i am
really curious to see if this is
something we already know
as fans about the wizarding world or if
it will be a completely new piece of
information
going back to my answer above about
avalanche's creative freedom here i
don't think it will be anything
earth-shattering to the canon we know
but i do see it likely being a way for
the devs to reveal something cool about
the wizarding world that maybe we didn't
know before
one of the other entries does confirm
our journey won't be limited to the
walls of hogwarts
wb says that hogwarts legacy will take
us beyond hogwarts to new and familiar
locations including the forbidden forest
and hogsmeade village
i think i'm gonna have to make a
separate video here because there are
some really exciting possibilities when
it comes to new and familiar locations
again seems like they have the creative
freedom here to take us places we've
never been before in the wizarding world
there's quite a bit more in the faq at
the time of this video recording the
site has 17 questions on the website so
it'll be interesting to keep an
eye on this to see how often it's
updated so check the other ones out and
let me know what you think down in the
comments below
if you're interested in even more
hogwarts legacy content check out the
playlist on the right side of your
screen right now
as always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon